there are two timing events that are
part of the window object that both
allow execution of code at specific
timing time intervals the two timing
events are set timeout and set interval
for set timeout you pass in a function
and milliseconds and the program will
wait the specified number of
milliseconds and execute the function
let's see some code okay here's the set
timeout function it could be window set
timeout but the window is implied you
pass in the name of the function which
is by and then here's the function down
here you also pass in the milliseconds
here so after 3,000 milliseconds which
is 3 seconds it's going to run the
function by which is just going to
console that log goodbye but before that
it's going to console that log hello so
let's run that 1 2 3 so you saw it said
hello and then goodbye it is possible to
stop the function from running after the
set timeout is called you must assign
the set timeout to a variable so Lubar
so we've set that to VAR time ID and
then we're going to call clear timeout
and pass in the variable so let's try
that it's going to say hello but it will
never say goodbye because we've cleared
the timeout the set interval function is
similar you pass in a function in
milliseconds but the program will
execute the function continuously
waiting the specified number of
milliseconds between each function here
we're creating a timer we're going to
set the count to zero and we're going to
call set interval pass in the counter
function and 1000 milliseconds that's
one second so every one second it's
going to call this counter function
where it's going to log count it's also
going to increment count 1 and we're
going to set it to an nth ID up here
I already have a button so in the button
we have an on click event that says
clear interval with an int ID the int
ideas down there we can stop the timer
by clicking the stop timer button and it
won't go on forever so let's run that
and see how that works well you can see
it's counting every second but if I
click the stop time button it stops so
clear interval just stops the function
in the set interval from running well
that's all for now thanks for watching
my name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good